et voilà c'était une chance sur un
million un documentaire d'Arnaud Muller
qui nous fait l'honneur de participer à
Z la Zone d'Éducation documentaire merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous aujourd'hui et
puis à vos côtés il y a une star du PSG
Colin Dagba bonjour merci merci à tous
les deux d'avoir accepté sur tout
l'invitation du lycée Martin Nadeau
bonjour les élèves
merci merci beaucoup d'avoir travaillé
avec votre professeur d'écogestion juste
avant de poser toutes vos questions
j'aimerais tout simplement que vous me
donniez votre ressenti Idris
j'aimerais bien aimer avoir un peu en
savoir un peu plus sur ce qui s'est
passé après pour chacun des trois jeunes
c'est gentil ça c'est bien que c'est
trop court
toujours
le déroulement du documentaire
merci est-ce que moi j'ai une question à
vous poser est-ce que vous trouvez que
c'est un héros d'y avoir réussi à être
pro quand vous regardez ce film
ce qui fait il fait partie de ces 1 pour
des millions exactement et vous vous
l'avez vu aussi ce documentaire qu'est
ce que vous en avez pensez vous êtes
retrouvés
parce que j'étais comme eux au palais
sport de Lévin c'est la même chose que
Clairefontaine mais dans le Nord donc je
me suis retrouvé par rapport à eux par
rapport à leur situation par rapport aux
échecs aussi qu'ils ont subi
l'éloignement avec les parents ça
c'était compliqué aussi au début au fur
et à mesure ça a été si c'est une
question
de foot dans un petit club près de chez
moi et après j'ai fait un autre petit
club près de chez moi et à 12 ans j'ai
intégré le Racing Club de Lens donc une
fois une équipe professionnelle et après
j'ai eu un échec à 15 ans j'ai pas été
conservé par le Racing Club de Lens et
est-ce que vous savez pourquoi ouais je
sais pourquoi en fait ils ont supprimé
une équipe parce qu'il avait un problème
d'argent donc ils ont ils ont viré 10
joueurs et c'était les moins bon entre
guillemets on va dire ils ont supprimé
il regrette aujourd'hui de t'avoir
lourdé alors que tu es obligé
en tout cas très jeune déjà vous aviez
envie de faire de faire ce métier en
tout cas et quand je suis arrivé à Lens
là j'ai vraiment eu le sentiment de
d'aller encore plus loin parce que c'est
un club que j'ai toujours supporté
j'allais au stade avec mon père quand
j'étais petit en plus c'était le grand
lance où je vais l'Europe donc c'est un
grand sentiment de sûreté surtout par
rapport à mon père quand je suis rentré
au centre de formation préformation dans
quel enfant
et Madame
vous retrouvez peut-être le plus ou
peut-être les trois en même temps
il y a des situations dans les trois où
j'ai vraiment vécu la même chose que
après je dirais plus Clarence parce
qu'il a vécu des échecs que j'ai vécu
aussi il a eu des pépins musculaires qui
font beaucoup douter comme moi j'ai eu
encore récemment mais ouais je pense que
ça ça va l'aider aussi à se forger parce
que moi ça m'a beaucoup aidé je pense
que ça m'a aidé à être là aujourd'hui
une question pour Arnaud Mella pourquoi
avoir choisi ce thème d'abord je suis
père de famille et j'ai un gamin qui
joue au foot et qui joue beaucoup au
foot et qui aime ça et depuis tout petit
et je me suis rendu compte que tous les
gamins de son club ils jouent au club
leur rêve c'est de devenir footballeur
professionnel de l'âge de 8 à 12 13 ans
plein de gamins rêves de devenir fou de
la professionnelle toi ça commence à
quel âge par exemple moi depuis tout
petit j'ai toujours voulu être
footballeur mais dès que je suis arrivé
à Paris vraiment c'était c'est là où je
me suis plus rapproché de d'un sentiment
d'être football
c'est vraiment un rêve et c'est ça qu'on
allait interroger en fait c'est ce rêve
ça représente quoi pourquoi certains y
arrivent pourquoi d'autres n'y arrivent
pas enfin c'est ça qu'on a voulu essayer
d'aller questionner et surtout
l'entourage les familles parce que c'est
hyper important l'entourage les familles
ça comptait aussi pour vous c'est très
important
ma première année ma première année
c'était dur parce que quitter les
parents une semaine sans eux on les voit
que le week-end mais encore le weekend
il y a le match donc on les voit un jour
vraiment
c'était vraiment dur au début après au
fur et à mesure ça a été après je me
souviens un moment un peu
un peu pas charnière maman qui m'a
marqué c'est quand j'étais pas conservé
à Lens je sentais en fait visualisais
comment dire la rate son départ en fait
alors qu'ils allaient pas du tout me
juger mais j'avais peur de la j'étais
plus déçu pour lui que pour moi en fait
j'avais quasiment l'alarme aux yeux
juste pour mon père parce que je me dis
je vais le décevoir et vraiment c'est un
moment fort est-ce que est-ce que vous
pouvez l'imaginer vous partir comme ça
très jeune pendant une année peut-être
même plus de votre famille et de revenir
une fois par semaine de temps en temps
c'est quelque chose que vous pouvez
envisager
si c'est le prix à payer si c'est ça qui
va me faire réussir je prends tout en
fait
il y a l'habitude de voir ses parents
pratiquement tous les jours de pas aller
voir pendant la majorité de la semaine
ce serait dur pour ça serait difficile
bien sûr d'autres questions oui Shaina
j'ai une quoi avoir choisi ces jeunes
pourquoi
précisément
alors je teste je déteste ce mot tu vois
le casting en gros mais on parle souvent
de casting dans un film dans un point
documentaire ça m'embête de dire casting
mais il faut effectivement parce qu'on a
besoin d'incarner les choses les
histoires et en fait
quand Clairefontaine l'école de
Clairefontaine m'a autorisé à tourner ce
documentaire en amont je suis allé faire
ce qu'on appelle du repérage c'est à
dire que tu vas rencontrer
les jeunes qui sont dans cette école
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps avec eux il
y avait un stage l'été au mois d'août et
donc je suis parti en stage avec eux
avec les coachs on a sympathisé on s'est
bien amusé et puis et puis ça se fait ça
se fait vraiment au feeling c'est à dire
que oui immédiatement
j'ai sympathisé avec des jeunes plus que
d'autres
voilà et ça s'est fait en fait ça s'est
fait très naturellement est-ce que vous
vous avez une une séquence particulière
un moment du film qui vous a
particulièrement ému ou toucher ou
c'était quand ils étaient tous enfin
devant je pense en stade et ils étaient
là en train de chanter rigoler ça m'a
beaucoup touché parce que c'était hyper
émouvant et voilà les moments de forêt
aussi oui oui on est en train de chanter
[Applaudissements]
attention ah ce qu'on a vu notamment
dans les centres de formation c'est que
vous êtes très pote parce que vous vivez
ensemble 24 heures sur 24
et à la fois vous êtes aussi en
compétition d'une certaine manière et ça
je trouvais que c'était assez fort aussi
à explorer enfin essayer de comprendre
ça c'est-à-dire que vous êtes pote mais
à la fois en compétition c'est moi je
pense que quand on est jeune comme ça on
soucie pas trop de la compétition et on
est plus là pour notre passion donc on
calcule pas du tout je pense c'est plus
dans les moments où on va faire des
tests moi j'ai fait environ une dizaine
de tests on va dire et c'était on a plus
ressenti l'esprit de compétition parce
qu'en plus on est beaucoup donc on va
dire va falloir se montrer aujourd'hui
parce que c'est une journée tu vas
revenir deux mois plus tard donc
aujourd'hui tu vas devoir tout donner et
c'est plus là où on ressent les moments
de compétition mais sinon quand on est
ensemble on vit une année ensemble comme
quand j'étais au Pôle Espoir franchement
à ce moment-là on pense que la passion
on prend du plaisir sur le temps il y a
pas de compétition est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
par exemple au PSG vous avez des amis
j'ai une grosse relation avec personne
qui vient on s'entend très bien
justement chez lui après
Idrissa Gueye aussi Abdou Diallo avec
son atelier le troisième gardien
quand bien même on sait que parfois
quelqu'un peut prendre notre place quoi
ouais c'est sûr après on va dire
vu qu'il y a beaucoup de concurrence
après il y a de la concurrence saine
aussi Neymar c'est ton pote on a du mal
à communiquer
je suis plus proche des Français
logiquement ouais normal et Killian
Mbappe
[Rires]
dans le foot dans le monde du sport il
est TTC il faut avoir du talon
ça c'est obligatoire si t'as pas de
talent tu n'existe pas
il faut avoir du travail il faut faire
du travail c'est le deuxième t
et le troisième le sait c'est quoi votre
avis c'est la chance
travail talent et chances qu'est-ce que
ça qu'est-ce que ça évoque pour vous ils
sont plusieurs à vouloir réussir et
pourtant un ou deux qui va être
sélectionné du coup c'est de la chance
c'est par rapport à la chance que tu as
que tu vas sélectionner et c'est vrai
que l'histoire de Colin elle est
clairement là-dessus c'est qu'en fait
c'est ta rencontre avec un lance avec un
peu de lance qui te dit à Boulogne vient
Boulogne c'est une rencontre qui fait
que finalement tu alors que tu as un
accident de carrière quoi à ce moment-là
ça te parle pour ça aussi le travail
talent chance c'est exactement ça parce
que par exemple quand on est chez les
jeunes à Boulogne ou à Lens tout le
monde a du talent parce que on peut pas
être là sans avoir du talent donc ça
c'est logique c'est la base d'un
footballeur un bon footballeur on va
dire après le travail dans tout ce qu'on
fait dans la vie le travail c'est
important et surtout dans le football il
faut travailler deux fois plus que
l'autre parce que sinon on va jamais
réussir et même c'était un peu moins de
talent le travail va toujours t'aider
dans la vie et surtout dans le foot
une expérience personnelle prouve que
que la chance on est obligé d'en avoir
c'est surtout les blessures qu'il faut
éviter
comment vous avez été sélectionné par le
PSG
en fait j'étais à Boulogne-sur-Mer et
j'avais 17 ans je commençais à jouer
avec la réserve et je commençais un peu
à fréquenter l'équipe première qui ont
un troisième division c'est le National
et donc mon agent un jour il m'appelle
il me dit il y a le Paris Saint-Germain
qui qui te regarde prends pas trop la
grosse tête continuer à jouer ton jeu et
continuer à faire les choses et ça va
arriver logiquement si tu continues à
bien jouer et un jour je reçois un coup
de téléphone
et c'était le recruteur du
Paris-Saint-Germain et je l'avais connu
à Lens ce que j'avais joué avec ses fils
et il était recruteur à l'ancien donc je
le connaissais je me souvenais de lui et
donc il m'a dit qu'en gros il me suivait
mais que il y avait rien de concret il
fallait je continue à jouer et que on
verra en fin de saison et donc en fin de
saison ils ont appelé mon agent et ils
m'ont proposé un contrat
ça t'a fait quoi quand tu reçois le coup
de fil du recruteur
mais après je le connaissais
pas une blague déjà ouais déjà
on le voit un petit peu dans le
documentaire mais c'est phases de ces
phases de tests dont vous parlez c'est
terrible quoi c'est vraiment comment
vous l'avez vécu enfin comment vous
l'avez tourné vous les on n'a pas pu
tout montrer dans le documentaire mais
ce qu'on a on a vu beaucoup de choses
mais ce qui est terrible et tu me dis si
je me trompe mais les phases de tests et
tout ça c'est
les recruteurs des grands clubs sont sur
tous les stades et ils contactent plein
de jeunes il y a plein de jeunes qui
passent des tests et au final là aussi
il y en a très peu qui sont sélectionnés
tu confirmes
sont tout le temps sollicités alors
c'est comme ça c'est les montagnes
russes parce que vous imaginez un
recruteur vous appelle comme Colin
bonjour je suis le PSG vous venez faire
des tests on se dit ça y est on est
arrivé enfin et en fait pas du tout
c'est le début d'une toute petite
d'un chemin qui va être très très long
et beaucoup beaucoup de monde qui va il
y a peu d'élus vous n'êtes pas rentré
dans le milieu du football en vous
disant quand même un petit peu derrière
si jamais ça marche pas qu'est-ce que je
pourrais faire ah si je me suis souvent
posé cette question sans cette question
mais même mon père il me l'a toujours
répété d'accord mais l'école devant le
foot d'accord toujours devant le foot
dès que j'allais des mauvaises notes
j'étais derrière moi pour m'aider ma
grand-mère j'étais en filière
scientifique ma grand-mère était prof de
mathématiques elle m'aide aussi beaucoup
donc ouais il m'a toujours poussé et
c'était quoi
je me suis dit je vais essayer quand
même rester dans le foot et dans le
sport je voulais partir soit en STAPS
essayer de faire kiné ou préparateur rue
du genre ça c'est l'obsession de tous
les parents des jeunes qu'on a suivi
tous les parents disaient jeunes il faut
qu'il y a un plan B parce que c'est pas
sûr vous n'allez pas peut-être pas y
arriver donc il faut un plan B c'est
l'obsession des parents parce que moi
par exemple dans mon équipe je me suis
fait un Boulogne en U17 le coach nous
répétait vous êtes 20 il y en a que un
ou deux maximum qui vont sortir et on
est à peu près 3 dans le monde
professionnel maintenant et donc je me
suis dit si je suis pas dans les deux il
faut toujours que j'ai que j'ai le choix
après et mon père il m'a toujours poussé
dans le sens là
quel a été le moment où la séquence que
vous préférez dans le film c'est quand
Clarence rémyre loupe complètement son
match il y a un tournoi c'est un tournoi
très important parce que justement il y
a plein de recruteurs et son année à
Bordeaux déjà ça se passe pas très bien
toute l'année il avait son son coach ado
il était pas toujours sélectionné et là
il se dit ce tournoi je vais tout donner
je vais y arriver et puis en fait il est
complètement son match il passe à côté
il s'énerve
je pense que quand on est jeune comme ça
et que des fois on sent que le vent il
tombe pas dans notre dans la bonne
direction je pense qu'il y a des moments
où on craque comme ça et quand c'est
difficile même quand peut-être par
rapport à son père comme je disais pour
moi on a envie de le rendre fier et
quand c'est dur aussi on se dit que il
va il va mal le prendre qu'on réussisse
pas
la sûreté
tu fais quoi
la musique ça me détend la musique
Gabriel
quelle est la différence entre être
réalisateur de films et celui d'un
documentaire le documentaire c'est le
récit de la vie
la fiction
c'est c'est l'imaginaire alors c'est
marrant que tu poses cette question
parce que après la diffusion de ce
documentaire j'ai été contacté par une
par une boîte de production de fiction
ils m'ont dit on a beaucoup aimé ce
documentaire on aimerait que vous
écriviez une fiction sur la base de ce
documentaire effectivement j'ai trouvé
ça très intéressant parce que parce que
on peut pas tout raconter dans un
documentaire parce que ce qui est pas
l'image n'existe pas et en fait on s'est
mis à écrire un scénario qui en
développement en ce moment et on va le
proposer à plusieurs plusieurs
chaînes de télé plusieurs plateformes
comment vous vous vivez votre célébrité
on va dire je suis plus en taille donc
je passe un peu inaperçu
de passer inaperçu mais ma célébrité on
va dire
j'essaye de vraiment pour les autres
j'essaie de dès que je rentre dans le
Nord un peu des démons club formateur
dès que je peux donner des maillots à
droite à gauche ou même donner des
conseils même être là devant vous pour
parler de mon expérience j'essaie de
faire profiter au maximum les gens parce
que je sais que c'est vraiment une
chance de d'être où je suis à ma place
qui a plein de gens qui auraient rêvé
d'être là donc je me prends pas pour je
sais pas qui on va me demander une photo
je veux dire non pas du tout donc
j'essaye vraiment d'espoir
pas de problème ça me fait vraiment
plaisir mais ouais j'essaie de rester
comme je suis comme mes parents ils
m'ont inculqué leur valeur et vraiment
vrai pour les autres on va dire
professionnel ici
[Musique]
du coup
pendant un match j'ai fait une crise du
coup mes parents ils m'ont ils ont ils
ont dû arrêter le foot du coup j'ai
arrêté
qu'est-ce que ça t'a fait de voir le
documentaire
professionnel et ça ça motive les
pour être footballeur professionnel tout
mon expérience de vie ça a toujours été
ma passion et ça arrivait un métier
quand j'ai commencé à gagner ma vie avec
je pense qu'on commence à gagner sa vie
et on commence à avoir des droits des
devoirs surtout vous avez du club on
peut pas s'amuser à faire des vidéos
faire n'importe quoi donc vraiment c'est
c'est ça devient un métier parce que
notre image elle est rattaché à celle du
club on peut plus déconner comme quand
on faisait qu'on était jeune donc c'est
vraiment à ce moment là où je pense
qu'on commence à gagner de l'argent et
même surtout une visibilité à la télé
etc et être une personne
par exemple on va dire pas forcément moi
pas un peu Mbappé c'est un modèle pour
beaucoup de beaucoup de jeunes Français
lui il peut pas il peut pas faire
n'importe quoi par rapport à son image
donc à ce moment là je pense que ça
devient un métier vous parlez de gagner
de l'argent vous avez commencé à gagner
de l'argent à partir de quel âge à
partir de
j'allais avoir 18 ans quand je suis
arrivé à Paris quand on était à Boulogne
on n'est pas d'argent mais on gagne
juste des primes de match quand on gagne
un match mais à Paris j'ai commencé à
avoir un salaire tous les mois on le
voit aussi dans le documentaire ils
peuvent être salariés très jeunes donc
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui vous
qui vous a qui vous a marqué ça le fait
que très très jeune on peut avoir un
salaire là c'est un métier non bien sûr
bien sûr c'est quand même
pour moi tout travail mérite salaire du
coup ils ont travaillé
par exemple ben vous tous les jours
enfin chaque match il y a des gens qui
vous regardent donc encore heureux que
vous gagnez de l'argent
et vu tous les paris qui se lancent à
chaque fin de match je pense que ça
c'est normal que sentir bénéfices bien
sûr il génère une réelle économie avec
ses pieds parce que eux ils gagnent de
l'argent en jouant mais derrière il y a
tout il y a toute une population qui du
coup qui apporte de l'argent justement
eux et les gens qui sont à côté par
exemple les
sélectionneurs par exemple ou plein
d'autres personnes
tous ceux qui font du foot ils font pour
la passion mais on sait aussi c'est
pourquoi faut pas se mentir on fait tu
fais si je fais ça parce que j'aime mais
je sais que il y a de l'argent derrière
si personne peut dire qu'il fait du foot
100% pour de la passion c'est mentir ça
tu penses qu'il y a trop d'argent dans
le foot j'ai juste qu'un intro mais si
tu me proposes la le salaire à Cristiano
Ronaldo je le prends
très vite même celui de bout de bouge je
le prends
ma famille il est très cash madame il
dit oui bien sûr mon rêve c'est aussi de
gagner de l'argent et de aider ma
famille
son premier salaire et il voulait
toujours dit ça sera pour ma mère quoi
je vais lui offrir une robe voilà enfin
c'est vous comment vous vivez ça
bah moi personnellement quand j'étais
jeune vu qu'il y avait pas forcément
d'argent autour de nous comme dans le
reportage quand ils sont très jeunes je
pense que j'avais même pas la notion de
l'argent dans le football ça a toujours
été la passion la passion et dès qu'on a
commencé à parler des primes de match à
parler de salaire quand je suis arrivé à
Paris là c'est sûr que c'est plaisant
mais au début on joue pas pour pour
l'argent pour la passion et après c'est
sûr que on gagne bien notre vie et on
essaie on a envie d'aider nos parents
donc comme il dit dans le reportage il
va il va aider sa mère directement donc
on pense plus à ça on parle souvent des
millions de la célébrité des paillettes
mais on voit très rarement le travail il
est sacrifices qu'il faut faire pour y
arriver et c'est ça qu'on a voulu
montrer dans ce documentaire c'est que
lui s'il est là où il est aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs ça me touche de t'en parler
parce que c'est c'est qu'il a fait
beaucoup beaucoup d'efforts beaucoup
d'efforts et qui est très fort là et pas
seulement là
Fatou une question pour Colin Dagba la
caravane un sportif c'est court et du
coup est-ce que vous avez pensé à ce que
vous allez faire après
franchement j'ai pas du tout pensé mais
j'ai vraiment envie de
peut-être pas forcément à prendre les
études ou peut-être une formation mais
j'ai vraiment envie de faire quelque
chose derrière et surtout apprendre des
choses parce que j'ai toujours soif
d'apprendre des choses et
même voyager à prendre des cultures
aussi j'aimerais bien mais on va dire
que peut-être reprendre mes études
j'aimerais bien mais je sais pas encore
dans quel domaine tu veux quitter le
sport quitter le foot franchement couper
je pense
me voir présentateur d'une émission de
foot ou un truc comme ça
c'est pas pour moi peut-être ça viendra
plus tard mais je pense que je vais me
couper du monde du foot
est-ce que vous allez faire une suite
pour nous montrer ce qu'ils sont devenus
les autres on aimerait bien on aimerait
bien il y a plein de choses à raconter
il serait tous d'accord
on espère
oui je pense oui parce qu'on a gardé un
très bon contact avec les familles avec
les jeunes aussi
donc ouais ouais j'espère qu'on fera une
suite ouais merci beaucoup merci à vous
merci merci à Arnaud Muller et Colin
dagboard d'avoir accepté de participer à
Z la Zone d'Éducation documentaire et
puis merci à vous les élèves du lycée
Martin Nadaud pour toute vos questions
et vos réflexions c'était vraiment très
très chouette et puis vous aussi devant
votre écran et bien si vous voulez
participer à l'émission si vous avez des
choses à nous dire n'hésitez pas à se
passer évidemment sur internet sur
Twitter # the doc et puis sur la page
Instagram de la Chaîne Parlementaire
alors évidemment à cause de la situation
sanitaire les premiers numéros de la
Zone d'Éducation documentaire surtout
plutôt à Paris et en région parisienne
mais très vite on viendra vous voir un
peu partout en France c'est promis et
puis on se retrouve très vite avec une
nouvelle classe et un nouveau
documentaire parce qu'il n'y a pas d'âge
pour questionner le monde et ces images
merci beaucoup salut salut les élèves
bravo bravo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]